thank you everybody so my name is Juan
Luis Cano and we're going to talk a
little bit about digital frame libraries
in Python with a particular attention to
Bowlers which has become my favorite
python library in recent years
and so first of all I'm going to do a
bit of an introduction and we're going
to talk about pandas which is the
library we all know and love what are
happening there it's success and also
especially what are the current
limitations
I'm going to gloss over some of the
Alternatives that exist today and then
I'm going to do a little bit of a live
demo to Showcase some of the
capabilities of folders
so first of all a few words about myself
so I'm an aerospace engineer and a
mission to accelerate the solidarity
economy through technology I'm currently
working as a data scientist Advocate at
orchest which is a company creating an
open source Pipeline orchestrator and
I've been involved with the python
community in Spain for the last 10 years
or so I created the python Spain
non-profit I organized the first seven
editions of python Spain a few years of
the Python Madrid meetups and at the
moment I'm organizing the by data Madrid
meetups so if you're ever in the capital
of Spain and want to uh
give a talk or just attend our meetups
you are more than welcome to do so
so feel free to reach out to me on
LinkedIn and follow me on GitHub and
yeah that's it
so a little bit of context of why we're
giving this talk so at our case we want
to empower data scientists and data
Engineers by developing a pipeline
orchestrator that is powerful but also
easy to use and we're noticing that the
extract and load faces of data
processing are increasingly being
commoditized by the transform is still
highly customized to each use case and
potentially very complex
so we set ourselves to answer the
question are our users using the best
tools available so we started doing a
little bit of research on what was out
there beyond the current tools that most
of the people are using we can focus on
data frame libraries first
and we cannot speak about data frame
libraries with python uh if we don't
mention pandas right so this plot here
that became quite famous five years ago
comes from stock workflow blog post that
describes the rise of python in the age
of data science and basically if you
break down each of the tags that the
stack or flow questions had you could
see that even though Django and flask
have been slowly increasing over the
years it has been the pi data stack and
fundamentally numpy matlably but very
especially pandas that brought python to
the position it is today so they have
been key to the success and we could
safely say that 80 or 90 of data
scientists out there use pandas or some
of the other python libraries
however pandas was designed
um some years ago with some assumptions
in mind that do no longer hold and made
some decision decisions in the design
that are no longer optimal so there's
this blog post by Wes McKinney the
creator of pandas
called Apache arrow and the 10 Things I
Hate About pandas that I highly
recommend you to read
and goes over some of these limitations
so basically the summary goes a little
bit like this
so many pandas operations don't really
take advantage of multi-core machines or
smart query planning on things like that
because of how the library is designed
so you know that with your performing a
chain of operations in pandas each of
these intermediate results needs to
exist in memory for the nest for the
next operations to happen and therefore
these can incur in some inefficiencies
because most likely pandas is Computing
things that we will no longer need down
the line
then there have been some efforts to try
to rewrite some parts of pandas so that
the Gill could be released or some parts
could be parallelized and there has been
mixed success so some things can be
indeed
successful to being paralyzed but some
others haven't
I'm seeing in the comments that the
sound is a little bit quiet it's not
sure if that's still the case but I will
try to compensate for that hopefully
that's a little bit better now
otherwise let me know
and apart from that
um pandas has some lousy memory
management technique with something so
for example the way missing data is
handled in pandas is a little bit
limiting there's essentially two ways so
one is declaring a sentinel value like
none or non or not a time not a date Etc
to
um signal that there's a missing value
there for whatever reason
this is more memory efficient because
you don't need to essentially duplicate
the data but the downside is that this
CPU cannot be as efficient going through
that data and then there's another
strategy which is uh having a Boolean
mask that essentially
um tells the library with a specific
value is valid or not and in recent
years especially after Arrow was created
this second strategy has been favored
much more strongly
the impenders has no native capability
of doing memory mapping and also the way
strings and categories are stored
internally are a little bit inefficient
so these are not huge problems for the
average practitioner but when people
want to apply pandas in production for
large quantities of data then this
starts becoming a problem
so what are the Alternatives then so I
started navigating the landscape of
current Alternatives in pandas to pandas
and it was kind of confusing at the
beginning I was not exactly sure what
each of these Alternatives were doing so
inspired by the famous quadrants by
Gardner I created the data frames
Charming quadrangle with some of these
Alternatives
mapped so on the lower left corner you
have the things that are most similar to
pandas and they are applicable for data
sets that are small or medium in size
and apart from pandas itself you have
Rapids so Rapids is a project that
brings pandas and other libraries to the
GPU so if you have a data sets that is
manageable by uh your local computer and
but you want to accelerate its
processing then you might be interested
in trying out Rapids if you have a GPU
to use it
then on the upper left corner we have
libraries that try to imitate the pandas
API to allow a simple transition from
one to the other but they bring it to a
distributed setting so essentially
you're able to process much much larger
quantities of data more or less with the
same API
the most famous of these ones is dusk
that has been around for many years
already and what it does is chunking the
data into smaller pandas data frames and
then scheduling all of that
um very efficiently
and then modding
um uses dusk under the hood and tries to
make even more seamless transition from
pandas to a distributed setting
on the upper right corner I called it
the recovering hadoopers there has been
Apache Spark all this time in pi spark
and the reality is that for some reason
the evolution of Apache Park in pi spark
has been kind of in parallel to the rest
of the pi data community and there
hasn't been much intersection but
nowadays they are converting more and
more for example now spark ships koalas
which is a pandas compatibility layer so
it's easier than ever to use pandas like
API or spark however there are many
people that don't like spark for
whatever reason
um and so we have on the lower right
corner some other libraries that don't
try to imitate the pandas API therefore
they don't offer an easy transition path
between the two but they offer some very
interesting things that are worth uh
exploring
so the first of those is Apache Arrow
aperture is not a data frame Library per
se in the sense that it doesn't have a
high level API that you can use but it's
the foundation for many other libraries
that have been created in recent years
so arrow is uh it defines itself as a
language independent columnar memory
formats
and that is designed for transient data
so not necessarily for storing data to
disk to store data to disk we have
Apache parquet and the feeder formats
and and it allows you to use it from
many different languages so the by Arrow
bindings use the C plus ones under the
hood
and then there's a native rust
implementation and there's many other
bindings in different languages
um for Arrow
and on top of Arrow there's polars so
polar's e markets itself as a lightning
fast data frames libraries data frame
library for rust and python is for
in-memory data frames even though they
have added streaming capabilities very
recently so we can process data sets
that are larger than Ram now doing out
of core processing
the most interesting thing about polars
and we're going to see that in a moment
is its expression system so you have a
series of uh very functional apis that
you can apply to the polarized data
frames and they are very elegant and
very efficient and polars is able to
optimize this list of Expressions
building a query plan very similar to
what traditional SQL databases have done
for many many years
and even though the project is very
young it was created in the middle of
the covid-19 pandemic in May 2020 if I'm
not mistaken and the project is really
promising and I've been using it more
and more recently
there are other projects that also
belong to this category so if you want
to know a little bit more about Arrow I
have a previous talk called the great
python data frame Showdown that I gave
out by data London 2022 you have the
recording online there's also dacdb
which is not really a data frame Library
it's more of in-memory SQL library that
you can use to transfer data between
that DB and Polaris back and forth you
can check out a blog post that I wrote
on the matter you also have Fugue which
is a unified interface for distributed
computing it has several backends for
example spark desk Ray and so forth and
there's also IBS that tries to provide a
unified interface a SQL like interface
in Python again with several different
backends
so without further Ado if
there are no further questions let's do
some demo time so I have here some data
pipelines that I'm going to use so I'm
going to
um download the stack Overflow sample
from kaggle and this is stack Overflow
sample contains roughly one percent of
all stack Overflow questions and answers
along with its tags so we're going to
process all of that
and I'm going to run through a notebook
that I already have that covers some of
the most interesting Concepts
um of borders so
first of all you can see that I can just
restart the kernel just in case
so you can see that I am using the
latest version of porus 0 or 15 1 at the
time of recording this talk which was
released less than a week ago and we
have a couple of CSV files here so we
have 1.8 gigabytes of questions and 63
megabytes of tags
and we're going to
um see if we can answer the questions of
what are the most popular python
questions in general and do some
expiratory data analysis here
so porus has a read CSV function
very similar to the band that's read CSV
that we're used to use
and these returns are polar's data frame
as you can see here
with a few columns and many many rows
you can see that the length of the data
frame is one million 264 something
something thousand rows and then the tax
is roughly three times that because most
of the questions have more than one tag
and we can check what are the D types of
this data frame so we see that we have a
few integer
columns and also some text or
categorical variables and also that
pullers allocated 1.8 gigabytes more or
less of ram to read this data in memory
at the moment
uh they were asking to increase the font
size so there we go
hopefully that's a little bit better let
me know otherwise and
and we can use some methods that we're
used to from pandas as well so for
example we have head to display some of
the first Lines by the way if you do a
print of a Polish data frame it has this
nice is ASCII representation it's quite
useful for copy pasting and stuff like
that
we also have a scribe that gives a
statistical summary of the data and then
we can do things okay give me the value
counts of the tags and then sort by
count and can be the most popular ones
so you can see that in this data set the
most popular tags are JavaScript Java
and c-sharp and you have and we have
um python over here
okay but this is very similar to what
we've done with pandas traditionally so
what are the interesting things
of polars so Polaris has this concept of
Expressions so as you can see I'm
declaring here a column called score and
then applying the median of that but
this dot call thing comes from polars
directly there's no data frame involved
here which means that this expression is
independent from any data frame where
it's applied to
right and then if I pass that expression
to some of the polar's contexts for
example select then it's going to
compute the result of that expression
for this particular data frame and this
is very powerful because it means that
you can decouple the data from the
computations that you want to express on
it
if you happen to pass more than one
expression like this then you can
compute several things and one for
example you can compute how many unique
IDs are there in this data set and give
it the name num unique users you can
compute what's the mean score globally
and call it means core you can see
what's the maximum length of the title
and then call that Max cycle length and
or you can
see what's the maximum length of all the
text columns which is super interesting
and then calling dates
um
with the suffix max length that will be
applied to each of the utf-8 columns
and the interesting thing is that
Polaris is going to apply all these
expressions in parallel because they are
completely independent from each other
so you don't need to wait for one to
finish to start doing the other one and
this is going to be as efficient as it
gets
the other interesting thing about polars
is that apart from the Str methods I
don't know if any of you has been
uh working with pandas data frames that
have a column of lists for me personally
it's a little bit annoying when this
happens because one needs to use the dot
Str methods also for this kind of a
series of lists which I find a little
bit unintuitive
and the thing is that Polaris has a
dedicated namespace for this which is
dot R and you can apply several methods
to that they're going to be specific for
um Columns of lists
okay so so far so good uh interesting
API but then what happens when we have
very large
um data so imagine that I now want to
join my data frame of questions with the
data frame of tags right if you try to
do that in this machine it's not
particularly powerful so I have a few
gigabytes of RAM only and doing this
join operation is going to crash my
machine so I'm not even going to try to
do that
but what you can try instead is to use
the lazy capabilities of polars and the
idea is that by calling uh an dot Lacy
method after uh
from an in-memory data frame then that's
going to allow you to chain a series of
methods that will not execute themselves
and instead they will accumulate in a
query plan that then you call with DOT
collects and that performs the results
so essentially I'm doing here a join
between the TF and the tags also with
the laser interface on the ID I'm doing
a semi-joint which is a magical join I
discovered with polars that is like an
inner join but discards the extra
columns
and then I'm filtering where the tag the
lowercase tag contains this the string
python right so
um
I'm essentially now having a data frame
that contains both the questions and the
tags themselves and I'm able to filter
that
um
all right
now I said myself a reminder to not load
both things at the same time
uh to continue and I'm going to wrap up
because I want to leave some time for
questions so
um you see before to use the lazy
interface I use the dot lazy method on
an in-memory data frame but what I can
do instead is to use uh scan CSV rather
than a read CSV that directly returns a
lazy data frame so this is not going to
load the whole data frame in memory and
instead it's going to scan it so that I
can make a more complex query
potentially without clogging my computer
RAM
so I'm now repeating the same joint that
I did before but now I'm sorting all the
questions by score descending and I'm
limiting that to the first uh Thousand
Ones
and the interesting thing is that I'm
storing that in a variable called plan
and then the result of the plan would be
plan dot collect but you can go and
visualize this query plan here with this
graph visualization where you can see
that there's on one side this CSV scan
and then there's a another table coming
from another site it's doing a
semi-joint some filtering and so forth
so polars is able to
devise this query plan very similar to
what dask does at another level
um but it's also going to optimize the
operations a little bit
so I'm going to close over the rest a
little bit more quickly so you can also
do list operations really easily for
example like group by ID and then
creating a list of tags for every ID
which is very convenient
um you can see if any of the attacks
contains the substring python because
potentially it could be like Python 3 or
python Dash something else and you can
do many other things so the whole
material is online I'm going to share
the link with you in a moment and so
we're going to close the demo time for
now and I'm going to head back to some
quick conclusions
so first of all what about the index
nowhere in all the code that I showed we
talked about an index and we're used in
pandas to have that and and for it to be
a very central part of all the
processing we do
and in fact there's a very opposed video
views about that so from the product
documentations they say the indexes are
not needed and not having them make
things easier convinces otherwise so a
pretty hard stance against indexes or at
least not in the sense that they're
completely required right but then there
are some other people like James Powell
very famous in the pi data community
that says that basically all the panel
operations are framed as transformation
and the index and that it's an essential
Cornerstone
what about desk then we also that this
is for a single machine but you might be
wondering what happens if I want to go
for a distributed setting and but using
polars right so it turns out
that Matthew rockling uh retrieving so
the creators of that skin Polaris
respectively have been working on a
prototype uh recently this was a
screenshot taken one month ago
and they're waiting for feedback so if
you want to let them know what exactly
do you expect from a distributed polars
Library let them know chime in and
participate in the conversation
so some conclusions pandas has some
limitations and inconsistencies by
imitating the pandas API you're
necessarily bound to reproduce some of
those inconsistencies and Polaris is an
excellent project that departs from the
pandas API but nonetheless
provides some very interesting
capabilities and I bet that in the very
near future there's going to be a
distributed solution based on borders
that's going to be awesome
so thank you very much a special thanks
to Kevin Co James Powell Cameron Fidel
Richie wink for giving some early
feedback on this talk inspiration
discussion and you can follow me there I
will share all the materials online and
I'll be happy to take any questions
thank you very much
all right uh thanks for the uh for the
presentation I think we've got a lot of
questions from our YouTube channel
uh the first one is asking would there
be a address where they can be finding
the demo notebooks
yes so the data Monroe books are on my
GitHub so if you go to github.com
and you will find them I'm not sure I
can share that right now on YouTube
because sharing links is a little bit
restricted there but anyway if you chime
in on Discord or just go to the uh
description of the talk online you will
see all these notebooks and you can
import them and do whatever you want
cool and uh another question we got is
uh would it be possible for us to
convert polar DFS to pandas yes indeed
so for example if you have these tags
data frame here that I have there's a
two pandas method if I'm not mistaken
there we go and then you see these
returns a panda's data frame uh directly
so yeah the conversion is really easy
gotcha and uh we have another question
that's the last question would be how
does the lady query work with a limited
memory
so how does the Lasik query work with uh
limited memory so the idea is depending
on the engine that you use there's the
conventional engine that was there at
the beginning of polars that still needs
all the intermediate results to fit into
memory but nonetheless it tries to be as
efficient as possible and avoid loading
results that are not going to be needed
then there's a streaming engine that you
can try so if you do dot collect
streaming equals true then this is not
optimized for Speed but optimized for
throughput instead and sorry not for
throughput I mean uh for for
out of core processing and you should be
able to process much larger data sets
with that this is quite new from the
recent versions
cool and um I think we'll be picking our
one last question asked by Daniel is
there any way to easily convert from
product table to pandas data frame or
the opposite
yeah for pandas for polars two pandas we
already did that uh to do the opposite
we have I think it's peel data frame
from
no I think yeah it's from pandas from
pandas and you can pass here uh pandas
data frame so essentially you could do
something like this I'm not sure if I
have enough RAM to do this yeah yeah I
do
cool all right I see that will be all
time we're having uh here for today I
could still see there are a lot of
crashing tasks on uh YouTube channel I
guess we can proceed to this part later
on again thank you Juan for coming to
the to hiding the global and thanks
everyone for joining us today
thank you thank you very much see you
all